well it is officially restaurant week
here in las vegas and rocky is live at
resorts world to see what's cooking for
a cause hi rocky
hey jillian yes what is cooking for a
cost let's talk to kate you're here with
three square what's the cause that
restaurant week is benefiting that we
love so much oh well it's gonna help out
three square southern nevada's only food
bank and you know rocky you know all too
well that unfortunately one out of six
individuals in our community doesn't
always know where their next meal is
coming from and so this is a great
chance folks to get out and give back
absolutely absolutely and have some
fabulous food we're all trying to
explore all the new places like resorts
world in our city and all the local
faves in our city as well so some what
are some of the restaurants that you
know are participating this year yeah
well just here at resorts world alone
there's 10 restaurants participating
which is huge and then you've got some
of your off the strip favorites like
honey salt
table 34 there's plenty there's todd's
english dining i mean the list goes on
and on there's over 200 places that
folks could participate um and get
involved with so i would encourage folks
to get to our website
restaurantweeklv.org and check out all
the places start making your
reservations because uh it's time it's
here it's here it's this is like the
bread and butter no pun intended for the
three square food bank it's like your
super bowl right you guys get geared up
for this week oh yeah there's there's
tons of planning and preparation goes
into this we're the only food bank that
actually produces a restaurant week in
the country um and the name i'll tell
you is a little bit deceiving it's
actually 12 days
so
june 17th yeah so it's not even just a
week you get 12 whole days to go out to
these incredible restaurants give back
to our community right and then give
back to the food bank at the same time
oh that is amazing so as you can see
we're getting some wagyu tartar prepared
over at cusa nouri here at resorts world
so coming up we're going to talk to our
executive chef chef ryan and see what's
exactly in that dish i cannot wait to
taste it thank you wow that looks
beautiful thank you kate we'll send it
back to you guys
wow that looked delicious thank you
rocky we will check back in with you
later on in the show